My three-year-old
contracted Lyme's disease that we discovered from having a fever fatigue and do-a-risk bullseye rashes covering his body. Is there still
Considered at an early phase or 14 days after doxocyclet is enough
So I think the question is three-year-old with Lyme
14 days
uptake-y doxocycline
or 14 days
after
go to seed after figuring out when this person got the tick bite
Therefore when they were exposed to the
Borrelia
so the truth so the answer to this is that a person could move from acute to chronic phase
literally overnight so
Most people it can most people it will take weeks to month for them to move to from acute to chronic phase
And for those who don't understand that terminology, let me explain briefly about Lyme disease so Lyme disease is
from a tick bite you get
Borrelia burgodorphy and
possible co-infections that enter that person's bloodstream that
bacterial infection in the bloodstream is going to cause
infectious
type symptoms acute infection type symptoms typically like this person said fatigue blue-like symptoms
fever
Some people it will show
a reaction in the skin and the typical reaction of
Borrelia the skin is a bullseye rash though
Both people that get Lyme disease never get a bullseye rash and a lot of people that get Lyme disease never show acute
infectious signs
So it's actually a blessing that you get these acute infectious signs in or
the bullseye rash because it's easily identified
Yeah, I think the one a person should do if this happens is that they should start on an antibiotic and
The most common antibiotic used for this is doxocycline doxocycline though a boxicillin can be just as as effective
The typical treatment from a Lyme literate doctor with doxocycline is going to be 30 days of treatment
Does a person the if the question is does a person need to continue
The whole 30 days if the answer is
No
That is just what's recommended
By the medical establishment I've had the Lyme disease at least twice. I think three times
And I took a boxicillin for it and I only took it two days one time three days and other time some people say that's foolish because you could leave chronic Lyme
In your system it works for me. I'm not a big fan of taking
Antibiotics for long term, so
But everybody's different of course, I'd ever take antibiotics. So works very well for me
And you'll know if you have a bacterial infection if take antibiotics then you feel about 80% better
suit after you take it so
If the question is that can you stop after 14 days of antibiotics that's up
You're going to have to discuss with the scribe doctor if the question is
Did we catch it in the acute phase after 14 days
Everybody's different. So I've had people that have taken antibiotics that felt 100% better stop the antibiotics after a full course of antibiotics
After a course of time two weeks to four weeks, they start their symptoms all over do the antibiotics again
knocks it out and
The whole course of antibiotics stop for a few weeks later comes back again
Then you know the Lyme the bacteria has body in the cell so the difference. We had a cute
Lyme and chronic Lyme is a cute Lyme
It it's still in the blood or it's in the tissues
It but in the extracellular space. It's not inside of a cell yet
So once a bacteria goes intracellular inside of a cell
Antibiotics are going to kill it. Your immune system isn't going to kill it either so
It can protect itself by hiding inside of a cell. There's multiple other ways that
Different bacteria like Borrelia protect itself and hide it mimic as your normal flora, but
We'll get into that right now
But if it once it goes inside of a cell now you by definition have product library what I call phase two lung and
You know, those are the people that they go on long long term antibiotics historically
for year two years
To knock it out because they did for every time it comes outside the cell and antibiotic is there to kill it
It can be very detrimental to all sorts of different
Body parts are here micrbiotis effective or effectively by doing something like that
That's what you see the right machine is a key component and then there's phase three line where you're you know your body is making antibodies
Again, self tissue many times in response to to the Borrelia in that tissue. So
That's the way your body's trying to kill the bacteria
So I I understood that question correctly
I gave you two answers
I didn't know I could understand that
Hopefully that helps